pese a que el centro de estudios
atmosféricos socio no gráficos y
sísmicos así como el comité de
contingencias han confirmado que tras un
pacto en territorio nacional el huracán
y otra se degradó a categoría 1 la
amenaza persiste ya que están cayendo
intensas lluvias en los departamentos
del sector nororiental y noroccidental
del país muchos de estos sectores han
quedado devastados por el paso de la
tormenta tropical etau aquí en
tegucigalpa ya se empiezan a sentir
intensas lluvias estoy justamente a
orillas del río choluteca que atraviesan
las ciudades gemelas de tegucigalpa la
capital y comayagüela todo este sector
las familias que viven por acá han sido
ya evacuadas toda esta zona quedó
completamente devastado por el paso del
huracán mitch en el 98 así que las
autoridades han tomado desde ahora
precauciones las evacuaciones masivas
continúan a nivel nacional miles de
familias son llevadas al albergue donde
se les da ropa alimentación y sobre todo
se insiste en las medidas de
bioseguridad ya que también está la
amenaza de la pandemia del gobi
19 sobre honduras